[Música]
hola muy buenas noches y bienvenidos a
este programa especial de france en 24 y
es que hoy dos países latinoamericanos
asistieron a elecciones claves por un
lado pero eligió a que será su próximo
presidente o presidenta y lo es o en
medio de una fuerte polarización social
y con dos candidatos que representan
modelos de país antagónicos mientras
tanto méxico vivió la que es considerada
la jornada electoral más grande de su
historia democrática vamos a comenzar en
pero íbamos a mismo a lima a la capital
del país para establecer contacto con
nuestro corresponsal francisco zacarías
antes les vamos comentando que bueno
perú tendrán nuevo presidente o
presidenta como les decíamos y lo harán
medio de una fuerte polarización
política a más de 25 millones de
personas eligieron este domingo quién
será su próximo presidente de francisco
ilusión entre dos candidatos que como
decíamos se presentan como representan
dos mundos radicalmente antagónicos
verdad pedro de castillo por un lado del
partido perú libre que en la primera
vuelta electoral se llevó el 19.09 por
ciento de los votos y por el otro lado a
la d
ya keiko fujimori de fuerza popular
quien obtuvo en abrir en la primera
vuelta el 13 punto 36 por ciento de los
votos quien sea ganador reemplazará al
mandatario interino francisco sagasti
vamos a saludar nuevamente a francisco
zacarías francisco contanos cómo han
transcurrido estos comicios al momento
santiago muy buenas noches estamos
transmitiendo en directo desde los
alrededores de la oficina nacional de
procesos electorales nos hemos movido
hasta este punto de la ciudad donde se
registra una marcha de protestas de
seguidores de pedro castillo tanto en
lima como en cajamarca donde se
encuentra pedro castillo sus parciales
han dicho que ellos rechazan estas
proyecciones que han dado
la bota esa boca de urna el conteo
parcial la boca de urna que posiciona a
keiko fujimori con el 50.3 por ciento
el sufragio y a castigo con 49 puntos 7
asimismo pedro castillo ha publicado en
el twitter que él llama a los
simpatizantes a movilizarse en las
calles del perú pacíficamente para
defender los votos y asimismo hace un
llamado a sus simpatizantes para
defender la democracia
cuál es el rechazo los simpatizantes del
pedro castillo consideran que él viene
representando la mayoría de votos de los
electores en todo el perú y no reconoce
en este primer lugar que hasta el
momento parcialmente tiene keiko
fujimori estos resultados parciales son
la boca de urna no son los totales no se
puede decir que ganó keiko fujimori y
perdió el pedro casi o porque hacen
falta el conteo oficial de los votos que
reciben la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales va a ser a las 11 y 30
la noche esta situación se ha venido
mostrando lo que ha sido esta campaña
una campaña política de ambos candidatos
que ha polarizado al perú y este como
venían señalando algunos analistas
políticos con los cuales hemos estado
conversando a lo largo de toda esta
jornada ellos dicen que esta situación
del resultado de las elecciones no le va
a brindar la estabilidad al perú que
necesita que ha venido atravesando
diversas crisis sino va a continuar
porque siempre va a existir una
situación en la cual ninguno de los dos
candidatos va
hacia ti si va a ser las ansias lo que
es él
resultado de las esperanzas de sus
simpatizantes siempre haber va a haber
un descontento por la opción que pierda
precisamente en cajamarca donde pedro
casillas se encuentra en estos momentos
pero estos simpatizantes han dicho que
rechazan estos resultados previos y que
esperan que los organismos oficiales no
tengan esta tendencia porque si no van a
continuar con una protesta masiva en
todo el perú francés francisco hablemos
un poco de las bases electorales no de
keiko fujimori y de pedro castillo no se
considera que castillo tiene más
electores no en lo que es el sector
campesino de las afueras de las grandes
ciudades y de la capital y más mientras
que keiko fujimori muy famosa por su
apellido un tema que más adelante en
este plano especial vamos a estar
analizando tendría mucha más base de
voto en lo que es lima la capital y las
grandes urbes es esto así
si precisamente pedro castillo
representa al perú profundo son
ciudadanos que demandan un cambio un
cambio al sistema político al sistema
económico y por eso él tiene las
preferencias del poblador rural se lo
estaba acusando de ser un representante
en la izquierda radical y las
acusaciones han sido mucho más agresivas
se lo ha relacionado con el comunismo y
con el grupo armado sendero luminoso
pero esto ha sido todavía hasta el
momento y me hizo como
un rechazo una parte de agresión de la
denominada 'guerra sucia' que se ha
establecido entre ambas las candidaturas
presidenciales pues bien pedro castillo
viene según el conteo a boca de urna
viene llevando en mayor presencia en 18
regiones del perú donde este conteo
parcial de votos de las encuestadoras lo
posicionan con el 18 por ciento de los
votos
mayormente emitidos hacia él mientras
que keiko fujimori señalan que tendría
victoria en sólo 8 regiones del perú
esta situación establece que la de nuevo
del proceso electoral todavía va a
continuar la polarización keiko fujimori
por otro lado podemos decir que
representa la continuidad del modelo
económico y del modelo político ella
tiene el respaldo
en los partidos políticos de las
empresas privadas y grupos económicos y
no solamente eso sino también han
recibido un respaldo del premio nobel de
literatura mario vargas llosa así como
de otras personalidades
la candidatura de keiko fujimori no ha
convencido al resto del perú que en
estos momentos está dividido entre
quienes apoyan a pedro castillo y
quienes defienden lo que es la
candidatura de keiko fujimori hay una
situación en la cual los ciudadanos
mismos han señalado que no es que todo
el mundo quiera a pedro castillo y otro
tanto que era keiko fujimori sino que se
vieron obligados a votar por estos dos
candidatos que no eran de sus
preferencias muchísimas gracias
francisco por este reporte volvemos
contigo en cualquier momento a lo largo
de estas dos horas en la que estaremos
llevando toda la información y también
el análisis de las elecciones
presidenciales en perú y de las locales
y legislativas en mexico
recordemos que perú viene arrastrando
una fuerte crisis política institucional
y también social y quien sea electo en
estos comicios sería el quinto
presidente en cuatro años y recordemos
que todos los ex mandatarios están
enfrentando causas
en su contra por lo menos los
exmandatarios de los últimos 20 años les
adelantamos que durante estas dos horas
además de llevarle toda la información
con nuestros corresponsales mario
carbonero en méxico y francisco zacarías
en perú con quien hablábamos recién el
análisis estará en manos de alfredo
fernández de lara gaitán él es
internacionalista maestro en políticas
públicas y también estará con nosotros
francisco belaunde y analista
internacional y qué les parece si
continuamos ahora conociendo el perfil
de keiko fujimori porque estamos
hablando de una persona muy célebre por
su apellido a diferencia de pedro
castillo quien saltó a la fama a partir
de ciertas manifestaciones en el año
2017 a continuación un repaso para
conocer quién es keiko fujimori
keiko sofía fujimori higuchi de raíces
japonesas y nacionalidad peruana hija
del polémico ex presidente del perú
alberto fujimori quien cumple condena de
25 años de prisión por violaciones a los
derechos humanos pero también madre
esposa administradora de empresas
política ex primera dama ex congresista
y presidenta del partido fuerza popular
la fama de su padre le jugó en contra en
las dos últimas elecciones pero esto no
impidió que su partido político se el
protagonista en este último gobierno en
el que lideraron el proceso de
destitución de tres presidentes en un
plazo de cinco años
aquí conoce conforman y mucho menos se
rinde y hoy por tercera vez lucha para
convertirse en la primera presidenta del
país suramericano
sin embargo en estas elecciones carga
con un peso que no cargaba antes su paso
por prisión preventiva en dos ocasiones
por presunta responsabilidad en lavado
de activos y otros delitos relacionados
con el escándalo de corrupción de
odebrecht pero ella se resiste a perder
insiste en que el país permanezca bajo
el régimen de la democracia propone
mejorar la educación reactivar la
economía
devolverle la seguridad a los ciudadanos
darle más importancia al medio ambiente
luchar por la igualdad para mujeres y
fortalecer el sistema de salud cuya
mayor responsabilidad actualmente es
vencer el kobe 19 de ganar quedarían en
libertad ella y su padre de perder es
probable que el fujimorismo nunca más
llegue al poder en esta nación y que el
país viva bajo una nueva ideología el
perú decide
y mientras tanto pedro del castillo es
profesor de marcado perfil izquierdista
y dio la sorpresa durante la primera
vuelta electoral en las elecciones de
perú el pasado 11 de abril castillo ha
creado controversia entre la derecha que
lo ataca asociándolo a sendero luminoso
y la violencia política del pasado su
postura en cuanto al aborto o el
matrimonio igualitario no obstante crea
controversia entre parte del aspecto
progresista del país y por el momento se
mantiene en cabeza de las encuestas
vemos el informe
un lápiz gigante junto a su ya
reconocible sombrero los dos símbolos de
pedro castillo o profesor de izquierdas
que fue el más votado en la primera
vuelta de las elecciones en perú ahora
por un estrecho margen lidera las
encuestas para la segunda vuelta un
hecho impensable hasta hace apenas dos
meses cuando castillo ni siquiera era
tenido en cuenta entre los favoritos su
gran propuesta es el cambio
constitucional para destinar el 10% del
pib a salud y educación discurso en
favor de los más desfavorecidos que
acabó por convencer el pasado 11 de
abril al 19% de los electores y les
importa un pepino cuando ve que el
hombre y la mujer en el pueblo mueren
clamando justicia castillo se dio a
conocer por primera vez durante la
huelga de profesores de 2017 ahora se ha
convertido en una figura controvertida
en perú su perfil marcadamente
izquierdista levanta pasiones entre
muchos especialmente entre la gente del
campo desde la derecha en cambio han
tratado de asociarse con cuba o
venezuela el hambre comenta disyuntiva
trump maoísmo que podían hacer
venezuela-cuba norcorea de lo peor
también con sendero luminoso y la
violencia política del pasado tras el
asesinato de 16 personas supuestamente a
manos de remanentes de este grupo el
pasado 24 de mayo en una zona remota del
país
ya le juzgamos abiertamente no solamente
ante él pero si no ante el motor a estos
rezagos de sendero luminoso y también
[Música]
en el campo progresista la figura de
castillo también es polémica pues está
en contra del aborto y del matrimonio
igualitario también rechaza la eutanasia
y el enfoque de género en las escuelas
un perfil izquierdista en lo económico y
más conservador en lo social
vamos a continuar ahora analizando esta
jornada de elecciones presidenciales en
perú esta segunda vuelta que enfrenta a
los modelos antagónicos de país junto a
nuestros invitados alfredo fernández de
lana y francisco belaunde mató ción él
es analista político internacional
francisco que según su punto de vista
que está en juego en estos comicios de
perú
buenas noches gracias por la invitación
que está en juego pues está en juego
realidad en gran parte un modelo modelo
económico que claramente ya está en los
dos candidatos a las antípodas
digamos otra vez aparece un candidato no
es la primera vez que un candidato como
un castillo con una propuesta digamos de
izquierda no de cambio aunque en esta
oportunidad y es lo que la diferencia
por ejemplo al caso de lo que yo creo
como un man la en su momento el ex
presidente humala en principio viene de
una de una tierra mucho más radical y
efectivamente en su momento con nexos
con esta organización que se llamaba de
fe que tiene vínculos declaró que es una
es empieza el organismo que viene de
sendero luminoso
además él está además él está aliado
común con él es parte de un partido
candidato en un partido cuyo líder líder
es claramente éste un líder que es
claramente digamos ultra y que arbitrar
si se no se puede decir bueno claramente
un 3 que artista la incógnita acá es
cuán radical es el propio es el propio
castillo
y hasta qué punto es una persona que
finalmente será pragmática ha dado
algunos indicios de que si es capaz de
convocar a personas que van más allá de
ese espectro no esté pero no quede muy
claro porque el punto también es bueno
pero entonces en que queda su compromiso
con él con el líder del partido perú
libre que él ha dicho que no no se le va
a ver en caso de ser presidente ni
siquiera como portero de traje expresión
que ha utilizado el problema que hasta
ahora pues es bastante más con portero
no les parece que fuera parece que fuera
efectivamente el bueno su socio bueno
como que lo es como que lo es no en el
caso de keiko fujimori pues
efectivamente se ha dicho en el
reportaje que ya que ha agregado pues
una mochila pues bastante grande
efectivamente ella representa un poco la
continuidad del modelo económico aunque
en la campaña
digamos nos ha ofrecido una especie de
carnaval de digamos de medidas que
podrían ser consideradas populistas
claro obviamente eso forma parte de la
campaña de barack que ver hasta qué
punto podrá realmente cumplirlas pero
claramente este sí es éste pues ella en
todo caso defiende defiende el modelo en
cuanto a lo que se refiere a democracia
por ninguno de los dos
ninguno de los candidatos ofrece muchas
garantías echo fujimori por representa
pues son un régimen efectivamente que
que propició un golpe de estado y además
ella misma tuvo un comportamiento muy
discutible un poco democrático cuando
éste las tras las elecciones pasadas
donde su bancada pues en el congreso se
y con rabia en buena parte a torpedear
la gestión del presidente electo pero
pablo kuczynski no le vamos a aceptar
muy pero muy de manera en no aceptar
realmente los resultados
y en el caso de el castillo pues
claramente esta vinculación con sectores
extremistas izquierda tampoco son muy
tranquilizadores entonces eso
desarrollen peor de los escenarios en
esta elección dos candidatos que no
ofrecen garantías en términos
democráticos y que tal vez la diferencia
bueno y además el caso de keiko fujimori
efectivamente ha llegado también a casos
de corrupción pero en el caso de
castillo pues su el señor es de su socio
el líder de perú libre es el señor se
ronda al emir cerró el también ha sido
condenado por corrupción y en segunda
instancia entonces bueno por ese lado él
tampoco puede ofrecer muchas garantías
entonces sí pues es una elección
terrible en ese sentido y avances o
viene desde la primera vuelta donde
efectivamente
y por decir alguna manera pues era
realmente algo así en una elección
saludamos alfredo fernández de la era
internacionalista señor fernández era
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
este programa especial de france 24
bueno hacíamos referencia a nado
previamente a la crisis política e
institucional verdad que arrastra perú
hace ya varios años de hecho ya sea
keiko fujimori o pedro castillo quien
sea electo presidente o presidenta sería
el quinto o quinta mandatario en cuatro
años no de aquí nos habla esta situación
porque considera usted que perú llegó a
este momento y además recordemos que
varios ex presidentes están en la mira
acusados y también siendo investigados
por la justicia por casos de corrupción
muchísimos vinculados a la constructora
brasileña odebrecht
y bueno buenas noches primero que nada a
todos si el caso peruano pues nos habla
de un caso que se ha vuelto digamos de
los más inestables en la región como
bien señalaba pues en entre 2016 y 2021
5 presidentes incluso una semana en
noviembre en que hubo tres presidentes
en menos de una semana entonces nos
habla de una inestabilidad y también
sumado a qué
el tema de que más de la mayoría de los
presidentes desde toledo hasta vizcarra
kuczynski etcétera
y la propia la propia candidata keiko
fujimori pues han estado relacionados
con plazos de derecho
obviamente nos habla de un sistema
político que si hubiera que
caracterizaron este momento no se
caracteriza por la inestabilidad se
caracteriza también por fuertes casos de
corrupción y creo que también lo que
refleja esta digamos esta contienda a
nivel a nivel regional es es un ejemplo
de esta marcada polarización que se
viene dando cada vez más en las en las
elecciones presidenciales en las
elecciones en los países de la región
entre esta retórica digamos de derecha
que busca mantener un status quo un
modelo económico neoliberal
y también una clase de gobernante en el
caso de perú pues prácticamente mantener
una especie de cuasi dinastía como el
circulo lo es la familia fujimori que se
enfrenta a una izquierda que es
etiquetada como castro-chavista pero que
es una izquierda que si digamos hay que
decirlo oscila entre posturas
progresistas pero al mismo tiempo
conservadoras digamos no hay como una
claridad ideológica en la izquierda un
candidato que podría ser catalogado como
un outsider y digamos que lo preocupante
es que gane quien gane pues pareciera
que el triunfo de una u otra de la
candidato del candidato no va a revertir
la tendencia a la inestabilidad política
en perú lo cual es preocupante pero
decir creo que perú nos da una muestra
de cómo cada vez más está enmarcado este
discurso a nivel regional en países como
colombia en países como méxico y en el
caso de perú entre todo lo que sea
izquierda está etiquetado como una
amenaza castro-chavista y por su parte
la derecha también tiene
continua
promoviendo ciertos modelos con cierto
modelo económico y además
independientemente de la izquierda o
derecha
el problema común que atraviesa la
región y que cada vez se hace más
visible y es preocupante es el tema de
la corrupción y entonces me parece que
en ese sentido pues el triunfo de uno u
otro candidato no va sobre todo en una
dirección que parece ser va a ser muy
cerrado el resultado podría abonar poco
a la estabilidad que en ese momento
requiere pero bueno alfredo como
veníamos diciendo esta campaña ha estado
plagada de acusaciones muchas bueno como
general casi todas las campañas
políticas no pero esta en particular
tiene el componente como usted decía no
por un lado keiko fujimori asegurando
que castillo sería digamos como la
venezolana acción no del país como usted
decía algo un argumento que ha sido
utilizado en muchísimos países argentina
brasil colombia incluso españa desde el
otro lado no pedro castillo asegura que
keiko fujimori sería como una de las
representantes detrás
es gobernadora del país y también apunta
contra la corrupción de la cual la hace
responsable ahora considera usted que
ambos representan o sea hacia ustedes
referencia a que castillo quizás no es
tanto para ustedes una democracia contra
la dictadura como si lo sería keiko
fujimori desde su punto de vista
yo no me atrevería a poner etiquetas de
que castillo sería una dictadura
o más bien lo que considero es que es en
ambos casos uno ve tendencias un poco
digamos poco proclives a consolidar una
democracia y más ciertos rasgos
autoritarios considero que digamos esto
incluso una discusión muy académica de
que en realidad mucho de lo que vemos en
américa latina son una especie de
regímenes híbridos que si bien tienen
ciertos elementos digamos de democracias
por ejemplo algo que habría que festejar
independientemente del resultado es que
al menos en lo electoral pues hay
incertidumbre y aparentemente se están
dando elecciones libres y competitivas
es decir que hay incertidumbre electoral
es un paso positivo para una democracia
electoral pero si pensamos en una
democracia más consolidada lo que vemos
es que en realidad tenemos este régimen
es digamos intermedios o híbridos que
oscilan entre posturas democráticas o
formas democráticas procedimientos
democráticos como son las elecciones
pero que veamos que en la parte llama
sustancia más sustantiva lo que tenemos
digamos tendencias de corte autoritario
tendencias hacia la opacidad
a eso me refería un poco obviamente
digamos esto no es una cuestión que sólo
se presenta en la derecha o que sólo se
presenta en la izquierda como la derecha
suele querer hacer prender entonces ahí
es donde viene un poco la parte digamos
de preocupación en el sentido de que
sobre todo en una elección tan cerrada
pienso por ejemplo lo que pasó en méxico
en 2006 es muy difícil que la otra parte
acepte su derrota entonces creo que lo
cerrado del por un lado es una paradoja
por un lado tenemos una elección que va
a ser muy competitiva pero a la vez va a
ser muy cerrada y entonces los dos van a
mantener la idea de que ganaron y eso
obviamente abona poco a la estabilidad
volvemos a saludar a francisco vélez
mato 100 señor francisco hablábamos
recién con alfredo fernández de lara
acerca de esta cuestión no de que sobre
ambos candidatos pesa esta suerte de
fantasma de riesgo no contra la
democracia por un lado keiko fujimori
bueno sobre que empieza también la
sombra de su parte alguien de su padre
perdonan a quien ella
defendido no de hecho últimamente ha
hecho declaraciones acerca de lo que
fueron en su momento las polémicas en
fertilización en los procesos de
fertilización esas mujeres durante el
gobierno de alberto fujimori por otro
lado castillo es acusado también de
tener vínculos con sendero luminoso cuál
es su postura respecto de esto que ha
marcado la campaña no la el fantasma de
el riesgo que corre la democracia en
perú estamos realmente ante un riesgo
democrático
bueno en parte sino en parte digamos los
dos candidatos te dejan dudas dejan
dudas
porque en digamos por los dos lados hay
antecedentes que no son muy buenos ahora
por otro lado
digamos esas esos temores se vayan a
concretar en uno u otro lado tampoco
queríamos vaya a ser necesariamente así
yo creo que hay una apariencia que hay
una ciudadanía bastante vigilante creo
yo que probablemente he llegado al caso
este de salta en las calles a digamos a
protestar en que no esté en caso de que
se den pues este intentos autoritarios
pero díaz y el yo sí diría que de alguna
manera estamos en una situación en la
que hay un riesgo hay un riesgo por
parte de ambos de ambos candidatos y esa
es la preocupación precisamente analizar
la preocupación que nos ponemos pero no
sabemos lo que puede venir
así que si yo sin ningún ningún tipo de
duda puedo decir que si hay un riesgo
otra vez no quiere decir necesariamente
que se vayan los temores se materialicen
vamos a verificarse en el relleno que
finalmente venga pero que si hay un
riesgo al riesgo un shock clarísimo los
invitamos a ver a continuación un
informe acerca de los últimos 20 años
que han marcado a la política peruana 20
años marcados por convulsiones y también
por varias crisis institucionales vemos
el informe
[Aplausos]
nueve presidentes en 21 años la muestra
de una convulsa realidad política en
perú
en noviembre de 2002 eventos ocurrían en
tokio y lima de manera casi paralela
mientras el entonces presidente alberto
fujimori renunciaba el congreso lo
destituía argumentando actos de
corrupción e incapacidad moral
permanente
[Música]
y por la patria tras la salida de
fujimori el presidente del congreso o
valentín paniagua asumió de manera
interina como mandatario unos meses
después el opositor alejandro toledo
ganó las elecciones
pero durante su mandato el país quedó
paralizado por semanas de huelgas en
diciembre de 2003 toledo exigió la
renuncia de todos sus ministros para
desactivar un escándalo de tráfico de
influencias que involucraba a su primera
ministra beatriz merino
a toledo lo sucedería en julio de 2006
el ex presidente alan garcía pero tras
dos años al mando su gabinete tuvo que
renunciar para impedir la aprobación de
un voto de censura en el congreso por
recibir pagos a cambio de concesiones a
la compañía noruega discover petroleum
en junio de 2011 el militar retirado de
izquierda ollanta humala ganó por un
estrecho margen a la hija del ex
presidente alberto fujimori keiko y se
convirtió así en el primer gobernante
izquierdista en perú en 36 años el 2016
keiko fujimori perdió de nuevo unas
elecciones presidenciales esta vez ante
el ex banquero de wall street- pedro
pablo kuczynski
pese a la derrota a su partido consiguió
una amplia mayoría en el congreso la
legislatura terminó con la renuncia de
kuczynski por posibles acuerdos con los
fujimoristas para indultar al ex
presidente tras ello llegó martín
vizcarra en septiembre de 2019 vizcarra
disolvió el congreso y en octubre keiko
fujimori fue enviada a prisión
preventiva 2020 sería el año de los
juicios políticos en septiembre el
congreso aprobó una moción para
destituir a vizcarra por presuntos
contratos irregulares con un cantante
pero poco después de salir airoso
comenzó el proceso de noviembre donde
finalmente se aprobó su destitución tras
ello fue investido manuel merino que
duró sólo cinco días en el cargo en
medio de intensas protestas desatadas
tras una moción de censura vizcarra que
parte de la población entendió como
fraudulenta la propia onu afirmó que la
policía había hecho un uso excesivo de
la fuerza el 17 de noviembre sería
investido francisco sagasti y tercer
presidente de perú en una semana y
último hasta las pasadas elecciones de
abril
keiko fujimori o pedro castillo serán
los décimos presidentes de perú en 21
años tras una segunda vuelta que
mantiene profundamente dividido al país
y vamos a ir ahora a mexico el país está
viviendo las elecciones más grandes de
su historia moderna de su historia
democrática mejor celebra este 6 de
junio unas elecciones que son locales y
también legislativas inéditas como
decíamos por ser las más grandes en la
historia moderna del país y cuyo
resultado decidirá el rumbo de la
segunda mitad del mandato de andrés
manuel lópez obrador el presidente
mexicano conocido como anv lo más de 93
millones de ciudadanos estuvieron
habilitados para ir a las urnas no sólo
se bomba votaron los 500 integrantes de
la cámara de diputados sino que también
hubo elecciones a gobernador en 15 de
los 32 estados se renovaron o se van a
renovar mejor dicho cuando se conozcan
los resultados 30 congresos locales y
unos 1.900 ayuntamientos en total
estamos hablando de casi 20.000
candidatos una cifra inédita en la
historia del país unos comicios
históricos no sólo por esto que les
comentamos sino también por un hecho
lamentable que tiene que ver con la
violencia que han marcado
este proceso electoral estos comicios
son considerados por muchísimas personas
como una suerte de referendo no para el
futuro o mejor dicho para el análisis y
la evaluación de lo que ha sido esta
etapa del gobierno de andrés manuel
lópez obrador
uno de los temas como le decíamos
principales de estos comicios tiene que
ver con la composición de la cámara de
diputados- que resultará de estas
elecciones
al momento recordemos y vemos en
imágenes que morena el partido
oficialista del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador cuenta con 253 escaños en
la cámara de diputados
y sus aliados contiene una mayoría
calificada esta mayoría calificada
recordemos que le permite tomar medidas
y aprobar reformas sin ningún tipo de
ningún negociaciones con otras
formaciones políticas tras acuerdos y
adhesiones morena ha logrado sumar 253
bancas más 47 pertenecientes al partido
del trabajo 21 del partido del encuentro
social el ps y 11 del partido verde
ecologista de méxico de esta manera el
oficialismo llegó a las 332 bancas la
mayoría calificada requiere de
recordemos de 333 o sea el oficialismo
estaba a una sola banca no de obtener
esta mayoría calificada aunque al
momento de votar las reformas siempre se
cuentan lo que son las dos terceras
partes de los diputados presentes al
momento de la sesión por lo que siempre
el oficialismo ronnie no logró reunir lo
que es la mayoría calificada recordemos
que la mayoría calificada es la que le
permite tomar resoluciones o realizar
modificaciones sin tener que negociar
con ningún otro partido
político son 500 diputados los que
conforman en la banca vamos ya mismo a
saludar a mario carbón el corresponsal
de france en 24 en méxico mario contanos
cómo han transcurrido estos comicios
hablemos de operativos de seguridad no
sólo por la pandemia sino también por la
violencia que ha marcado a este proceso
electoral no recordemos que alrededor de
90 políticos fueron asesinados 36 de
ellos eran candidatos a cargos públicos
así es pues es una jornada que ha tenido
una participación abundante de la
ciudadanía como bien lo comentaba son 93
millones de ciudadanas y ciudadanos los
que fueron convocados este día a las
urnas y a pesar de que aún está la
pandemia de kobe 19 las medidas de
seguridad sanitaria que se tomaron han
funcionado bien las casillas ya cerraron
en todo el país y la autoridad electoral
ha salido a dar un primer balance un
primer balance en el que califica la
jornada de exitosa de las 162 mil 570
casillas únicamente 30 no pudieron ser
instaladas por algún motivo de
inseguridad esto es 99 puntos 73 por
ciento de las casillas se instalaron
correctamente y los mexicanos pudieron
salir a votar es cierto que ha sido un
proceso electoral marcado por la
violencia son más de 30 candidatos
asesinados en un proceso en el que
también ha habido agresiones
físicas secuestros amenazas y se
intensificaron hacia el final hacia la
recta final de las campañas ha sido
también un proceso electoral en el que
la intervención del presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador ha sido un factor
el mandatario asegura que es parte de su
libertad de expresión que él no puede no
informar en sus conferencias mañaneras
de lo que está ocurriendo y de cómo ve
el proceso electoral mismo sin embargo
pues ha habido más de 80 impugnaciones
de los partidos de oposición porque
consideran una injerencia una
intromisión del presidente en el proceso
electoral e incluso el tribunal
electoral del poder judicial federal y
en dos ocasiones señalado que en efecto
el presidente con los comentarios del
presidente en sus conferencias han pues
de alguna manera violentado en la avda
que hay para pronunciarse respecto de
los comicios
pues esto se ha convertido en una pugna
en realidad entre el ejecutivo y la
autoridad electoral tanto la
administrativa en este caso el instituto
nacional electoral como la judicial que
es el tribunal electoral sin embargo
bueno a pesar de todo ello a pesar de la
pandemia de la violencia de la pugna
entre la autoridad en este caso el
presidente con los organizadores de la
elección ha sido un proceso
participativo en la propia secretaria de
gobernacion olga sánchez cordero ha
dicho que la jornada transcurrió en paz
de manera pacífica y democrática sin
embargo no ha sido exenta de incidentes
focalizados algunos de ellos de cierta
gravedad hablamos por ejemplo en el
estado de mexico con la presencia de
grupos
claramente con el objetivo de entorpecer
de obstaculizar la jornada comicial de
grupos armados con palos con tubos en
algún municipio por ejemplo en naucalpan
si se identificó se logró detener a un
grupo en metepec también el estado de
mexico si llegaron a las agresiones a
los golpes e incluso al destrozo en
algunas casillas o bien en tijuana la
ciudad fronteriza con eeuu se arrojó una
cabeza humana en una casilla de votación
para claramente intimidar a la población
el robo de urnas en oaxaca por ejemplo
se robaron 800 boletas electorales para
impedir desde luego la participación de
la ciudadanía sin embargo pues han sido
algunos incidentes que la propia
autoridad considera aislados focalizados
y que no han obstaculizado en términos
generales esta jornada electoral que
como bien lo mencionas
son de especial importancia para el
segundo la segunda mitad del mandato del
presidente lópez obrador porque está en
juego si en su partido morena y los
aliados el partido verde el pez y el pp
conservan la mayoría calificada que
ahora apenas si alcanzan con algunos
movimientos para poder llevar a cabo
reformas constitucionales las reformas
que el presidente aún quiere llevar a
cabo antes de terminar su mandato en el
senado hay que recordar no tiene la
mayoría calificada
y bueno es ahí donde reside la
importancia de estos comicios hay unos
estados algunas gubernaturas que son muy
disputadas es el caso por ejemplo de
nuevo león en donde el partido
revolucionario institucional el pri se
disputa cara a cara con el partido
movimiento ciudadano ambos candidatos el
del pri adrián de la garza y el de
movimiento ciudadano samuel garcía han
salido a declararse vencedores en una
contienda problemas cerrada y así es el
caso en otras en otras jornadas en otros
estados donde
se renueva el poder ejecutivo estatal
aquí en la capital del país son 16 las
alcaldías que se renuevan y el congreso
local evidentemente y será a las 11 de
la noche cuando se conozcan los
resultados del conteo rápido que lleva a
cabo el ine el instituto electoral para
la cámara de diputados y para las quince
gubernaturas del juego variado carbones
gracias por este reporte volvemos
contigo en cualquier momento saludamos
nuevamente a francisco belaunde
internacionalista para seguir analizando
lo que son las elecciones en méxico unas
elecciones que tienen en su punto
central a la que será la composición de
la cámara de diputados- resultante de
estos comicios esto es clave verdad para
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador sobre todo de cara a las
modificaciones no que quiera realizar
por ejemplo a la constitución del país
claramente eso es clave efectivamente
tener una mayoría calificada
por lo que he estado leyendo pareciera
antes para los resultados pero que
pareciera que esta vez fuera vaya de
enero para tener una tal vez una mayoría
incluso menor mayoría de dos maneras
pero menor eventualmente que la que la
que la que tenías ahora en la cámara
diputados por lo tanto se le va a ser un
poco más difícil llevar a cabo esos
proyectos lo que sí hay que resaltar
efectivamente el uso respecto a lo que
se ha visto los hechos reportajes son
esos ataques al organismo electoral no
es el saldo de parte del presidente de
la república pues es bastante delicado
y eso llama la atención en cuanto a
llamamos al compromiso institucional del
presidente respecto del sistema
democrático en méxico y a eso se añade
definitivamente también la violencia
lamentablemente es aún la de asesinatos
no de políticos y también de entre los
cuales esté buena parte de ellos son
candidatos eran candidatos debemos
pintar un cuadro un poco complicado
también no es una característica de
nuestros países lamentablemente por una
u otra razón compartimos este escenarios
este complicado para la democracia en
ese sentido no estamos pasando por el
mejor de los momentos en cuanto a
nuestros sistemas democráticos no tanto
en mexico pero como en otros países como
estamos viendo
ahora aquí proyectos de andrés manuel
lópez obrador podrían llevarse a cabo en
caso de que conserven o lo que es la
mayoría
lo que lo que imprevisto es que
eventualmente una de sus propuestas
sería reemplazar el ine electoral cuyas
funciones serían asumidas por el
ministerio el interior como
efectivamente ocurre en nuestros países
pero claro donde hay una mayor
institucionalidad democrática como es en
el caso de chile o en europa en todo
caso y después el tribunal electoral
también reemplazarlo por el poder
judicial que dicho sea de paso está un
poco el medio la controversia por esta
decisión de lópez obrador de tener no de
más allá del término legal de ampliar el
término del presidente de la corte
suprema entonces ese proyecto pues en el
caso que lo pueda digamos llevar a cabo
pues este es un poco es un poco
inquietante el otro tema también eso de
atacar a la normativa de transparencia
también diciendo que elegir tiene un
gobierno transparente por lo tanto este
no hace falta un organismo como ese
también el caso que buscar a
desaparecerlo pues también sería algo
algo este preocupante acá en perú se ha
creado un organismo de ese tipo no
lamentablemente todavía no tiene muchas
y en muchos dientes como se dice no para
forzar a la administración entregará
información proporcionó son un paso que
se ha dado no seguir lamentable y ver
que en los hermanos en méxico pues éste
se estuvieran retrocediendo en ese
terreno no sólo vamos nuevamente alfredo
fernández de lara para seguir hablando
no de la mayoría calificada y la mayoría
absoluta recordemos que la mayoría
calificada en la cámara de diputados de
méxico implica tener por lo menos 333
bancas un tercio de la conformación de
la cámara y esto implica que quienes
detengan o quienes obtengan esta mayoría
calificada no tengan que negociar con
ninguna otra fuerza política cualquier
propuesta modificación en la
constitución etcétera no obstante la
mayoría absoluta si requiere de la
negociaciones con esas fuerzas alfredo
en caso de que se pierda la mayoría
calificada a qué escenario ve usted no
para méxico en el juego de fuerzas
bueno digamos que él
se espera que tengamos que digamos la
mayoría simple la mantenga la mantenga
morena y la coalición que formó
compartidos como el partido verde y el
pez pero creo que digamos
habría algún partido bisagra o también
se puede esperar que en algún momento
digamos haya
por ejemplo diputados de cierto partido
pequeño que pueda
que pueda en su momento digamos apoyar a
pasarle los ojos o sumarse a la
coalición de andrés manuel ahora yo creo
que en un sentido democrático no es
grave que no tenga la mayoría calificada
digo que también eso sería importante
como un contrapeso al gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador y que tengan que
negociar y que tengan que respetar en
caso de que la ciudadanía así lo decida
un congreso digamos plural un congreso
dividido y creo que en realidad eso
sería sano para la democracia creo que
también digamos que pues en un sistema
presidencial en el que los contrapesos
son importantes no no lo vería como una
digo más como una cuestión problemática
de sí y dificultaría digamos la toma de
decisiones o la fácil y digamos el apoyo
que hasta el momento ha tenido andrés
manuel en el legislativo pero tampoco es
sería la primera vez que en méxico hay
un congreso dividido de hecho
cuando llegó andrés manuel hacía por lo
menos 20 no 20 o más años yo creo que
desde desde previo al 1997 que no había
un congreso en el que el presidente
tuviera una mayoría calificada entonces
creo que en cierto sentido en cierto
sentido eso es sano porque también se va
a promover la pluralidad
ahora como te decía también eso esto no
esto es parte de las negociaciones que
se hacen y a lo largo también de digamos
de que se vayan sabiendo los resultados
pues se conocerá si en algún momento
también alguno de los partidos pequeños
que logre ciertos votos pues pueden en
algún momento funcionar como una especie
de partido bisagra y logre y logre
darles ese respaldo
andrés manuel hay que reconocer que
dentro de todo dentro de estas esta idea
también digamos de que de que andrés
manuel el tiende a ser muy autoritario
pues hay que hay que valorar también que
en cierto sentido hoy se está expresando
que méxico
al menos en la parte procedimental pues
hay una democracia en la que digamos
también hay incertidumbre sobre los
resultados hay elecciones libres y
competitivas hay un ambiente de
violencia lamentablemente pero también
hay que matizar porque sea cómodo
difundido esta idea de que estas son las
elecciones más violentas y si bien han
sido unas elecciones violentas no
necesariamente si lo vemos por ejemplo
en el número de homicidios dolosos han
sido las más violentas y habría que
señalar que en la elección federal de
2018 hubo 152 candidatos o que fueron
lamentablemente asesinados con esto no
quiero minimizar la violencia pero sí
señalar que no es la elección más
violenta en términos digamos por lo
menos en cifras de asesinatos y esto
también demuestra que digamos que el
tema de la violencia viene desde mucho
atrás digamos que si se ha mediatizado
más y si es preocupante que haya que
haya violencia pero también hay que
verificar verificar los datos y de hecho
esto te lo que te puedo visitar la
fuente
unas cifras que señaló una grupo de
análisis que se llama select en el que
mencionan que de hecho y lo muestran con
gráficas que la elección más violenta
fuera de 2018 precisamente a
continuación vamos a hacer referencia a
estas cifras que da este lector que como
decíamos una vez más lamentablemente la
jornada electoral en mexico y todo el
proceso previo hasta desembocar en ella
ha estado marcado por la violencia
asegura un informe de la consultora de
telegate entre el 7 de septiembre de
2020 y el 21 de mayo de 2021 se han
cometido 782 agresiones contra políticos
del país un 1% más respecto al ciclo
electoral de 2017 2018 que dejó
recordemos 774 muertos durante toda la
campaña en mexico
la tónica han sido las amenazas sobre la
vida de los candidatos de acuerdo con
los últimos datos durante todo el
proceso electoral con corte a la fecha
del 21 de mayo perdieron la vida a cerca
de 89 políticos de los cuales 35 al
menos eran aspirantes
es a puertos de puestos de elección
popular un registro que es un 41 por
ciento inferior a los 152 políticos
entre ellos 48 candidatos asesinados en
la anterior campaña electoral de global
de políticos asesinados este año el 75%
eran opositores a los gobernadores de
sus respectivos estados una tendencia
que se incrementó respecto al anterior
proceso electoral del 69 por ciento
violencia política en mexico 2020 2021
hablemos ahora de cifras durante ese
periodo se registraron 700 82 agresiones
contra políticos contra 89 personas
políticas fueron asesinadas 35 eran
candidatos mientras que el 75% de las
víctimas mortales eran candidatos
opositores
vamos a continuar analizando ahora este
tema de la violencia que ha marcado
lamentablemente toda la campaña
electoral en mexico y no solo esta
campaña ha sido también estado muy
presente en otros procesos electorales
la violencia se ha vivido de manera muy
particular en el norte del país por
ejemplo en la ciudad de tijuana
fronteriza con eeuu se han vivido
episodios espeluznantes cabezas de seres
humanos han sido arrojadas a centros de
votación también a entidades del partido
político morena es una de las zonas más
afectadas por la violencia precisamente
en esa ciudad fronteriza se encuentra
nuestra corresponsal
anabella guzmán ella nos reporta va
previamente sobre la violencia que marcó
a esta región de méxico escuchemos la
baja california se une desde luego
también a esta jornada electoral 2021 en
unos comicios que llaman la atención no
solamente de la prensa a nivel nacional
sino a nivel internacional ya que se
empata por primera vez en la historia en
baja california la elección para decidir
quién será el próximo gobernador o
gobernadora así como las alcaldías y
también las diputaciones locales y
nacionales en medio de estas elecciones
llamadas intermedias que como lo hemos
estado comentando son importantes pues
baja california busca luchar contra un
enemigo que siempre ha estado presente
el abstencionismo y es que los datos más
recientes de las últimas elecciones en
el 2019 hablan de hasta un 70 por ciento
de personas que no acudieron a emitir su
voto bien pues la lucha será ahora
precisamente tratar de acaparar a este
electorado ya que estas personas lleguen
a las urnas que precisamente las tenemos
ahorita en pantalla para emitir su voto
una jornada que se ha visto empañada por
algunos incidentes violentos como
precisamente en la capital del estado
de urnas desde temprano también el
ataque a balazos al inmueble a las
oficinas del partido morena el partido
que se encuentra en el poder a nivel
nacional pero no sólo eso en otro
municipio en rosarito un ex presidente
municipal fue detenido momentáneamente
porque se le acusó de tener propaganda
política en su vehículo sin embargo
minutos más tarde se confirmó que la
información era negativa y bueno se le
dejó ir sin ningún problema aquí en
tijuana aquí en tijuana desde donde nos
encontramos reportando han ocurrido
algunos hechos violentos y preocupantes
y es que por la mañana fueron lanzadas
dos cabezas humanas en bolsas de
plástico así como restos también manos a
casillas del este de la ciudad lo que
provocó que la de la apertura de estas
casillas buenos se retrasará en lo que
la policía hacía las diligencias para
tratar de investigar qué era lo que
había ocurrido algunos empujones algunos
conatos de violencia que han acontecido
y bueno la policía y la guardia nacional
ha tenido que intervenir
evitar que esto se salga de las manos y
que las elecciones se sigan
desarrollando como debe de ser en medio
de un ambiente de calma es importante
mencionar que en baja california se
instalaron un promedio de cuatro mil
casillas cerca de 33.000 personas 33 mil
ciudadanos fungieron como funcionarios
de casilla apoyando precisamente toda
esta contienda y bueno para tratar de
dar agilidad a los cerca de 2.9 millones
de personas que están en el padrón
electoral de baja california y que
podrían y que deberían mejor dicho
también emitir su voto este es el
panorama desde tijuana baja california
méxico era el reporte de nuestra
corresponsal en tijuana anabella guzmán
acerca de la violencia en esta ciudad
del norte de méxico fronteriza con eeuu
vamos a continuar analizando la
violencia que ha marcado a estas
elecciones ya todo el proceso electoral
previo junto a nuestros invitados
saludamos saludamos ahora a alfredo
fernández de lara alfredo bueno la
violencia como decíamos marco no solo
con las elecciones sino también todo
este proceso previo según usted a que se
puede atribuir no esta violencia de
donde data
y perdón algo que quisiera agregar
quienes cree que están detrás
mira cómo es digamos ya conocido y en
otros espacios se ha debatido pues la
violencia no es que méxico siempre ha
tenido digamos procesos a lo largo de la
historia no podrían rastrear procesos
electorales más o menos violentos
digamos que lo que ha pasado en méxico
es que de 2000 desde 2007 había un
incremento en la violencia en términos
generales sea digamos que el número de
homicidios dolosos que ha tenido méxico
en los últimos cinco años pues son son
terribles con su cuestión que se empezó
a disparar desde 2007 sin embargo creo
que en cuanto a esta violencia previa
digamos lo que quiere decir es en
marcarlo en un ambiente o en un entorno
de violencia generalizado en el país en
gran parte por la lucha que existe entre
los diversos cárteles digamos la disputa
por las rutas las disputas por el
tráfico hacia de estupefacientes hacia
estados unidos y también el narcomenudeo
y que se han extendido es decir luchas
entre grupos criminales
tanto entre ellos como entre frente al
estado sin embargo en el caso específico
de lo que venimos viendo con la
violencia política yo creo que hay una
mezcla no no tengo los digamos los datos
específicos en cuanto a poder corroborar
esto es algo que digo a nivel digamos
más como hipótesis de que no solo es la
la violencia no sólo favorece a los
grupos criminales también favorece
digamos a los contrincantes y un dato
muy importante que nos da esta encuesta
que señala que ustedes se citaban es que
75 por ciento de la violencia que se ha
ejercido se ha ejercido contra políticos
que son opuestos al
digamos al gobierno que en este momento
está gobernando en el nivel subnacional
otro indicador interesante es que la
mayoría de la violencia se ha presentado
en los municipios es decir
sobre todo hacia candidatos que
contienden por puestos en el nivel
municipal o en nivel estatal recordamos
que méxico es un sistema federal
entonces ahí creo que también podría
haber una mezcla que no solo
necesariamente favoreciera o fuera
promovida por los grupos criminales que
buscan capturar a las instituciones
también podría ser violencia política
como tales es decir de políticos hacia
políticos y que queda digamos en esta en
una nebulosa en el que digamos en ese
entorno de violencia generalizada pues
es muy difícil diferenciar en cuánto es
la violencia entre un por parte de un
contricante político hacia otro o cuando
el violencia criminal ahora lo cierto es
que también los grupos criminales pues
buscan favorecer sus redes de protección
y como el sistema político mexicano
sobre todo después del 2000 se fragmentó
digamos de un sistema de partido
hegemónico como lo fue el pri y a partir
del 2000 empezaron a ver más actores
pues obviamente esto genera ha generado
una serie de reacomodos para los grupos
criminales grupos criminales que
obviamente buscan también tener acceso
al poder político y en algunos casos yo
creo que ya ni siquiera buscan redes de
protección sino lo que buscan es
directamente poner
candidatos que favorezcan sus
actividades que por ejemplo puede
controlar el nivel municipal para poder
actividad realizar esas actividades y
obviamente esto también ya nos llevaría
no sólo un tema de violencia sino un
tema de búsqueda por parte de los grupos
criminales de capturar directamente las
instituciones democráticas y ahí incluso
por ejemplo hay casos como el de san
luís potosí en el que los candidatos a
gobernadores ya han han sido digamos
cuestionados por posibles nexos con
grupos de este tipo entonces digamos que
también hay ahí una una violencia una
mezcla entre violencia que puede ser
promovida por los grupos criminales a
violencia que también puede ser
violencia política en el sentido de
promovida por los por otros grupos o por
otros intereses políticos a fin de
quitar a su contrincante pero digamos
esto es muy difícil de corroborar lo que
sí creo es que también hay que tener
como ese tipo de digamos de matices para
tampoco caer en generalizaciones que nos
pueden llevar también a
a general ser volvemos a establecer
comunicación con francisco belaunde para
seguir hablando de la violencia que
marcó estos comicios locales y también
legislativos en mexico y le quiero
preguntar según su punto de vista
francisco cómo impactan estos actos de
violencia en el electorado no cree que
hay una suerte de efecto de intimidación
bueno habría que ver las cifras habría
que ver las cifras de votación
obviamente esto este tipo de ataques
siempre también tienen un efecto de de
asustar a asustar a las personas
pero había que ver no sé no sé con en
estos momentos cuáles son las las cifras
porque claro todavía no hay no se han
anunciado pero sí obviamente la
violencia la violencia asusta y nidia a
las personas este y claro de alguna
manera pueden distorsionar resultados
resultados este de los resultados
electorales entonces quienes son los
factores efectivamente digamos que
afectan al sistema democrático en su
conjunto pero como digo no sé cómo habrá
sido el digamos en términos de digamos
de parte de asistencia no esté en las
elecciones en particular en aquellas
zonas no en aquellas zonas donde se
producen
y el grado de violencia habría que
esperar en casa
volvemos a saludar a mario carbon el
corresponsal de france 24 para
preguntarle precisamente acerca de la
violencia no un tema que veníamos
hablando con nuestros invitados analista
mario respecto de la violencia cuál ha
sido el clima social que has podido
percibir así en méxico sobre todo
también en esta jornada electoral
claro hay algunos estados donde si
marcadamente podríamos decir que mermó
un poco el ánimo por los ataques estoy
hablando de guanajuato guanajuato un
estado pues en donde hay fuerte
presencia de grupos delictivos como el
cartel de santa rosa de lima y disputa
por lo que se ha dado en llamar el
guachi coleo que es no es otra cosa que
contrabando de combustibles y pues ahí
han asesinado una candidata muy bien
ciudadano
esto crispó un poco los ánimos también
en sonora en cajeme también de
movimiento ciudadano asesinaron a un
candidato allá y bueno pues hay otros
estados donde hay más calma hay digamos
una percepción de mayor tranquilidad
y otros donde la violencia no es de ese
tipo sino más bien de grupos de choque
como aquí en la ciudad de mexico que ha
habido algunos altercados pero que no
han pasado a mayor yo creo que como bien
lo comentan habrá que esperar las cifras
de participación ciudadana
a lo largo del día de la jornada los
reportes han sido de amplia presencia de
los votantes en las casillas a mí
particularmente me tocó ver largas filas
hacia el mediodía preguntando en algunas
casillas en la que me tocó votar por
supuesto como había estado el ánimo y al
parecer pues al menos aquí en la capital
del país todo transcurrió en orden
fueron en un millón y medio de
funcionarios de casilla
los que participaron que son ciudadanos
que son digamos no son funcionarios de
gobierno sino son los vecinos de las
alcaldías los que participan en la
organización y en la ejecución de esta
jornada de votación de tal suerte que
pues sí
el clima de violencia
apegado de manera distinta en la
geografía del país veracruz por ejemplo
es uno de los estados donde con mayor
fuerza se manifestó lo que el gobierno
mismo llama el partido del crimen
organizado es decir aquellos municipios
en donde la delincuencia quiere imponer
algunos candidatos o quiere evitar que
lleguen otros
y ahí se dio un caso por ejemplo también
de desaparición de una candidata
en fin el estado de méxico son lugares
en donde el crimen opera y donde se vive
de distinta manera este clima de
inseguridad que sin duda pues marca a
todo el país pero que insisto se da de
manera distinta en cada en cada estado
muchísimas gracias mario por este
reporte volvemos contigo en cualquier
momento y regresamos nuevamente a perú
recordemos a nuestra audiencia ya
quienes están sumando en estos momentos
que estamos en un programa especial de
france 24 dedicado a dos jornadas
electorales que vienen dos países
latinoamericanos dos elecciones claves
por un lado méxico donde hay comicios
regionales locales y también
legislativos y por el otro lado en perú
donde en segunda vuelta de los
ciudadanos fueron a las urnas para
elegir a dos candidatos opuestos que
llegaron a la recta final en estas
elecciones presidenciales que estamos
hablando de keiko fujimori la derechista
keiko fujimori hija del polémico alberto
fujimori y por el otro lado el candidato
de izquierda pedro castillo sin embargo
ninguno de estos candidatos parece
convencer por completo a todos los
ciudadanos que ante esta situación se
inclinan por elegir al mal menor o al
menos peor como se dice en muchísimas
partes por un lado hay quienes le temen
a las propuestas de izquierdas depedro
castillos mientras que otros no perdón
algunos de los hechos atribuidos al
fujimorismo adriana villacorta nos
amplía en el siguiente informe
pedro castillo y keiko fujimori agua y
aceite él es líder de izquierda y ella
de derecha por lo que las posturas de
los ciudadanos están muy divididas no
vamos a perder de estas libertades no
vamos a tener a un dictador
tenemos que pelear por la democracia no
queremos ser un venezuela no queremos
ser un cubano queremos ser un knick
aragua queremos defender nuestras
libertades de esto los simpatizantes de
keiko han vinculado a castillo con el
grupo terrorista sendero luminoso en más
de una ocasión además dicen que sus
planes de gobierno amenazan a las
empresas transnacionales y organismos
constitucionales de hecho parte de sus
ofrecimientos son estatizar el país y
redactar una nueva constitución por otro
lado el antifujimorismo ha cogido mucha
fuerza en estas elecciones es una
organización criminal con gobernado con
su padre dijo algo cuando su padre se
iba a esterilizar a las mujeres del
campo en contra de su voluntad no fue
cómplice y no solamente eso quiere tomar
el poder porque sabe lo que le viene
detrás del crepe de la carne
delito gravísimo que cometió los
peruanos están cansados de ser
gobernados por corruptos y keiko ha
estado involucrada en el caso la valla
pto
por eso se adentran en el tema de las
elecciones ante el futuro que se les
avecina ha aumentado el interés de los
peruanos en la campaña electoral
respecto a lo que vimos en la primera
vuelta que era un elector desconectado
totalmente de la elección ahora si vemos
mayor preocupación mayor seguimiento en
la campaña ante los extremos que
presentan los candidatos al balotaje por
la presidencia de perú firmaron un
acuerdo para respetar el orden
constitucional del país sin embargo hay
dudas de que cumplan su promesa
volvemos a lima a la capital peruana
para continuar ampliando la información
y conocer más detalles sobre esta
jornada electoral que se vive en perú
junto a nuestro corresponsal francisco
zacarías francisco hay más novedades
acerca de sondeos a boca de urnas sobre
la participación básicamente sobre los
diversos datos que hacen digamos a cómo
transcurrió esta jornada electoral
bueno en realidad los sondeos de boca de
urna todavía están registrando los
avances de las preferencias que han
tenido los peruanos en las diversas
regiones del perú en paralelo todavía se
espera el pronunciamiento de la oficina
nacional de procesos electorales que a
las 11 y 30 de la noche va a dar cifras
oficiales hasta el momento no hay un
vencedor declarado al 100% ni tampoco un
derrotado lo único que podemos decir es
que las reacciones que se han presentado
tanto en lima como en otras ciudades del
perú es que hay el descontento de los
parciales de pedro castillo quienes
están saliendo a realizar protestas
justamente a mi espalda hay un
contingente de la policía peruana que
está resguardando el contorno de la
oficina nacional de procesos electorales
que es el organismo que dirige a las
elecciones en este país
precisamente los simpatizantes del
castillo han tildado de fraude a estas
elecciones y han anunciado que yo
a partir del día lunes van a realizar
plantones de protesta ante todos los
organismos electorales en la otra acera
del frente se encuentra que con fujimori
quien ha recibido estos datos la boca de
urna en total calma con junto a su
familia y algunos amigos en la candidata
keiko fujimori se ha mostrado
complaciente y con carme ante estos
resultados y no hemos recibido la
información de que ella va a esperar el
primer reporte la oficina nacional de
procesos electorales para luego emitir
un pronunciamiento este primer reporte
va a ser a las 11 y 30 de la noche pero
no va a ser al 100% va a ser
aproximaciones que va a irse
actualizando con el transcurrir de las
horas porque este proceso es largo
porque primero el organismo va a
cuantificar los votos que se han emitido
en las ondas urbanas de lima y otras
ciudades del interior del perú después a
partir del día de mañana baja
el acceso a los votos que han sido
emitidos tanto en las zonas rurales de
los andes' así como de la selva del perú
y a partir del día martes recién van a
llegar a contabilizar los votos que han
sido emitidos en el extranjero hablando
con una fuente de estos organismos me
contó que se espera que más o menos
entre el viernes y el sábado pueda tener
el mayor alcance de esta proyección y
ver cuál es la tendencia que va a seguir
dando a quién sería el probable vencedor
de estas elecciones de segunda vuelta en
el perú volvemos con francisco belaunde
internacionalista que nos está
acompañando ayudándonos a analizar tanto
las elecciones en mexico común en perú
quisiera preguntarle al señor belaunde
si cree no que en este contexto que se
vive
en perú no de crisis institucional no de
que vamos a conocer al quinto presidente
en tan solo cuatro años de hecho hubo un
periodo en el que en una semana hubo
tres mandatarios en perú cree que
teniendo en cuenta todo este contexto
estamos ante una suerte de referéndum
ante lo que es el sistema político y
social peruano
esto podría considerarse tal vez un
referéndum sólo la posibilidad de que
haya una nueva constitución porque
claramente eso fue la propuesta de
castillo entonces en cambio por supuesto
en el caso de los francos fujimori
ella más bien defiende la constitución
cuyo origen se sitúa precisamente en el
régimen de su padre es guerra también
que esa constitución ha sido modificada
varias veces desde que se dio en 1993 de
modo que no es exactamente la
constitución que se dio en ese año pero
obviamente el diamond de su origen como
fue en el caso de la constitución de
chile además del régimen de pinochet
también tenía pues un origen un poquito
complicado por decirlo de alguna manera
no
de algunas y de si yo podría decir que
sí de eso está un poco también en juego
en esta elección
ante los pedidos que hayan mejoras en la
propia el propio banco de equipo con han
dicho que por supuesto se pueden hacer
cambios no pero de ninguna manera una
nueva constitución digamos que reemplace
a la actual entonces eso es una más en
general el sistema político lo estamos
viendo no en todas partes del sistema
político tanto en el perú como el
colombiano en muchos lugares como que
necesita eventualmente un ajustes no hay
una desconexión y eso tiene que ver
también con la caída de los partidos
políticos en general una desconexión no
entre entre el sistema y los políticos y
la ciudadanía bastante marcada entonces
sin duda sin duda yo creo que es algo
que también nos toca a nosotros en el
perú y que de alguna manera habrá que
afrontar más
añade que se haga o no una nueva
constitución pero si hay reformas
claramente que son que se han comenzado
a implementar
pero que eventualmente tendrían que ser
profundizadas alfredo fernández de la
era quisiera charlar con usted de ahora
acerca de algo que quizás porque bueno
estamos hablando muchísimo de dos
modelos radicalmente antagónicos no dos
modelos de país dos visiones de mundo
pero hay quizás un punto en el que según
muchos se unen no tanto pedro castillo
como keiko fujimori verdad y es en lo
que refiere a la agenda social de hecho
desde sectores del progresismo son
sumamente críticos con castillo respecto
más que nada por los derechos de la
comunidad lgtb y también de las mujeres
se podría decir que en medio de tantas
diferencias digamos lo que une tanto a
keiko fujimori con pedro castillo es
este conservadurismo a nivel social
sí es un poco lo que planteaba
anteriormente que en realidad tenemos
unas una en américa latina' suelen
presentarla en algunos países izquierdas
que en algunos temas sobre todo buscan
una ruptura si hubiera un tema en el que
buscan una ruptura es el no económico
pero si lo vemos en la parte de digamos
mantener ciertas estructuras
tradicionales
sobre todo por ejemplo en temas
familiares en tema de religiosos pues
son izquierdas que en realidad
terminarían siendo muy conservadoras no
entonces ahí es como como una
contradicción porque terminan
pareciéndose en eso o terminan digamos
respaldando el modelo que también los
gobiernos más deportes de derecha que
digamos que es parte de su de su papel
terminan digamos pues pareciéndose mucho
en eso no entonces lo que lo que yo yo
creo que en el caso en el caso peruano
también es relevante es que el tema de
la discusión de la constitución pues
parecería que por
es que fujimori buscaría una dimos
keiko buscaría la continuidad mientras
que castillo una ruptura pero creo que
también ese discurso habría que tomarlo
con cierta cautela porque el problema no
yo no creo que el problema de fondo en
latinoamérica sean en países como perú
como méxico el problema quizás no es de
constitución el problema no es de
instituciones incluso me atrevería a
decir el problema desde el grado de
institucionalización y de
democratización y de digamos de captura
que tienen esas instituciones a lo que
habría que profundizar es la
institucionalización y evitar
precisamente las capturas de las
instituciones y cuando habla de captura
lo relaciono con el caso de odebrecht
usar seis presidentes dos o más
presidentes de perú una candidata futura
o posible presidenta de perú
involucradas todos en no debe social o
que es lo que nos muestra es que
finalmente el tema de la corrupción
terminó a nivel regional y en el caso
peruano resalta incluso sobre sobre
otros casos y habría que también
entonces pensar como para él
más que la constitución también esta
elección podría ser un referéndum en y
lo hemos visto incluso en las cápsulas
en contra de la corrupción y hay un tema
que no hemos tocado ni en el caso
mexicano en el caso peruano que pero que
también creo que influye mucho en algo
que podríamos denominar el ánimo del
electorado que sería el tema de la
pandemia y de las gestiones poniendo el
caso peruano pues no no quiero pensar
que no quiere decir que el caso mexicano
es un caso de éxito
pero el caso peruano si no voy a ponerlo
los indicadores sobre todo en términos
per cápita pues habla de una mala
gestión también pues por un lado tenemos
un gobierno que se caracteriza o una
candidata que se caracteriza por nexos
familiares
digamos relacionados con corrupción e
incluso a ella bajo investigación y una
mala gestión también de la pandemia y yo
creo que eso también son variables que
quizás las encuestas no no sé qué tanto
lo pueden medir pero que creo que cuando
veamos los resultados también vamos a
ver cierta sanción del electorado hacia
la gestión que se ha hecho en esas
materias
hablemos alfredo un tema clave no en
estos comicios tanto en méxico como en
perú pero estamos centrándonos en perú
hablamos por supuesto de la pandemia del
virus del cob y 19 pero con una
población cercana a los 32 millones
tiene ya casi 2 millones de contagios
1.980.000 estos según cifras de la
universidad johns hopkins y 186 mil un
poco más de 186 mil decesos estamos
hablando del país con la tasa de
mortalidad por habitante más alta de
todo el mundo no como deberán enfrentar
o como crees que enfrentaría no teniendo
en cuenta las diferencias entre ambos
candidatos esta crisis sanitaria a keiko
fujimori se ha hecho varias promesas al
respecto no incluso prometió entregar
ayuda económica a los familiares de
personas fallecidas
si alfredo le trasmitía para usted era
esa pregunta perdón perdón sí no
definitivamente pues el tema digamos es
yo prefieren poco al tema del ánimo del
esperado porque digamos que ya lo que
venga después de la elección pues son
medidas que se tendrán que tomar usa la
pandemia sigue y el tema por ejemplo del
lado de la forma en que los países se
han capacitado para o han desarrollado
capacidades o implementado el tema de la
vacunación pues va a ser muy importante
el tema es que no lo hicieron antes de
la elección y es y ahí ya lo que venga
después pues ya sería más una cuestión
paliativa o reactiva que digamos que
tendrá que sancionar el electorado en
otro proceso que en esta edad creo que
en este lo que se lo que pasó es que hay
una mala gestión y pues digamos que ahí
la que ha tenido más participación y
actividad política en la cámara ha sido
keiko en cambio castillo pues ha sido
digamos más desde una postura como
candidato incluso como un político más o
más por fuera del sistema que dentro del
sistema entonces ahí habría que ver
también que pues en cierta forma keiko
tú tendrían una mayor responsabilidad al
respecto
ahora quisiera retomar el contacto con
francisco quisiera preguntarle si
considera bueno en este congreso
heterogéneo o no que hay en perú es otro
factor que podría unir tanto a keiko
fujimori con como a pedro castillo el
hecho de enfrentarse a un congreso
digamos bastante heterogéneo y en ese
sentido no tener digamos tan fácil la
gobernabilidad
pues hay una diferencia porque en el
caso de keiko fujimori y ya tiene tiene
ya hay una alianza con un partido
partido más importante que esa alianza
para el progreso claro es un parlamento
fraccionado
pero digamos ya tiene un aliado con uno
los de este grupo de la alianza para el
progreso que claramente otros dos
partidos de derecha van a estar
seguramente con ella trabajando y ya
podría alcanzar y efectivamente podría
alcanzar una mayoría este este sino
absoluta pero muy cercana en todo caso y
para ella sería un poco más este más
fácil la gobernabilidad y es
precisamente lo que algunos temen dicen
teniendo en cuenta los antecedentes
autoritarios del humorismo pues éste el
viejo para la democracia sería mayor que
en el caso del castillo ahora en el caso
de castillo como tiene esta estar ahí
los antecedentes en otros países donde
presidentes que han sido elegidos
digamos presidente de cortes y artistas
que han sido elegidos y tenía una no
tenían mayoría en los parlamentos pues a
través del mecanismo de una asamblea
constitucional
digamos podríamos tener un cambio en la
constitución y después bajo las nuevas
reglas disolver el congreso no y
propiciar la elección de uno nuevo que
bajo el impulso de su popularidad
eventualmente impulsada por medidas de
corte social los llevan a obtener una
mayoría absoluta y ahí eventualmente dar
libre curso a impulsos autoritarios o
socialistas por ejemplo en el caso de
ecuador el propio caso de venezuela y
demás entonces ese es el riesgo no sea
son son dos figuras totalmente distintas
y que tendrían un congreso otra vez que
donde sí podría tener en alianza con
otros partidos una una sino una mayoría
absoluta pero muy cercana en el caso de
el caso d
de castillo no pero está la posibilidad
no de la asamblea constituyente por eso
es tan importante diríamos en esta
agenda que eventualmente por ese que
para muchas personas el electorado no es
lo más importante pero claramente es una
propuesta de castillo y seguramente sin
duda la va a incrementar porque también
la propuesta de sus aliados actuales que
son los de la antigüedad relativa del
movimiento nuevo perú el antigua
candidata verónica mendoza entonces sin
duda va a intentar éste llevar a cabo
esa agenda del cambio constitucional lo
que le permitiría después eventualmente
obtener un congreso más amigable
continuó con usted para preguntarles lo
siguiente no que viene a colación de lo
que estaba mencionando recién respecto
de estos presuntos no riesgos para la
democracia ahora por supuesto sin tomar
ningún tipo de partido no o keiko
fujimori tiene digamos acciones y
declaraciones concretas no que podrían
ser consideradas anti democráticas el
apoyo a muchísimas acciones de su papá
como decíamos al comienzo del programa
como las
acciones forzadas más de 2.000 mujeres
han denunciado que durante el gobierno
de fujimori fueron esterilizadas sin su
consentimiento con consecuencias
tremendas para su salud también ha dicho
que indultaría a su padre quien cumple
condena por delitos de lesa humanidad
entre otros pero sobre el perro del
castillo hay cuestiones digamos
concretas más allá de quizás vínculos
con sendero luminoso etcétera para
hablar de un con una concreta amenaza a
la democracia quiero decir hay quizás
más elementos para considerar que keiko
fujimori tiene un historial más
peligroso contra la democracia que
castillo
bueno si es la famosa frase sobre uno
tenemos dudas sobre nosotros tenemos
certezas ahora obviamente el castigo no
ha sido gobernante y este es un nuevo y
su recién llegado a la política el
problema con él este día incluso más
allá buenos hablados sus vínculos con
alguna gente el mover de fuera sobre
todo él es parte es candidato de un
partido perú libre cuyo líder ella ha
demostrado este un talante autoritario
cuando es porque él es un ex gobernante
griego regional nos hacía gobernado éste
ha mostrado un talante autoritario y
éste su discurso es claramente
autoritario y además también digamos
éste ha sido condenado como único por
corrupción y por ese motivo él no ha
podido ser candidato a presidencia por
eso tuvo que recurrir a alguien como uno
pero castigo ha postulado como
vicepresidente pero ha llegado el caso
pues no podría ejercer porque piensa
sobre él también una inhabilitación
entonces
si bien digamos si vienes de arranque en
el caso fujimorismo pues hay una larga
trayectoria de digamos de autoritarismo
sin embargo en el otro caso pues hay una
alianza en el caso del castillo no con
un común parte con el líder de un
partido que es claramente
antidemocrático y el problema ahora que
ver qué pasa también comienza a bancadas
por lo menos más de la mitad de esa
bancada es gente de el señor cerrojo
entonces uno por eso es y bueno si vamos
a poner porcentajes o aliens en términos
de porcentajes no pueden efectivamente
no hay más probabilidades por lado de
keiko fujimori y menos por el lado de
castillo pero no habrá que eso es
consuelo bastante poco entonces yo creo
que más allá de eso estamos ante dos
candidaturas que sí plantean serias
dudas serias dudas para
digamos la plena vigencia de la
democracia lo cual otra vez no quiere
decir que los temores se vayan a
concretar pero si los motivos de
preocupación en ambos casos existen más
o menos según uno u otro pero existen
entonces eso yo creo que acá es lo
sustancial y implica por lo tanto una
actitud implica que toda la ciudadanía
va a tener que estar vigilante con las
gestiones de uno o de otro eso es
clarísimo francisco velarde sabemos que
tiene que retirarse le agradecemos
muchísimo su presencia en este programa
especial de france 24 su análisis ha
sido de muchísima utilidad tanto para
nosotros como para nuestra audiencia
gracias por haber participado
gracias por la invitación bueno lo
tenemos ahora con alfredo fernández de
lara alfredo quisiera consultarle acerca
de bueno estábamos hablando recién de
estos presuntos riesgos a la democracia
no usted planteaba en un principio
hablamos bastante al comienzo de este
programa especial sobre esta suerte de
fantasmas de venezuela no desde que la
posibilidad de que los países se
transformen en venezuela una estrategia
política o una realidad concreta
pues si hubiera que quedar la evidencia
yo creo que parece más un tema de
marketing que se ha venido usando en
distintos países como para sobre todo
por grupos de derecha como para digamos
vender esta idea de que se puede
transitar hacia venezuela pero pues si
vemos la evidencia hemos tenido
gobiernos de izquierda en la región y
pues no no tenemos digamos una venezuela
expandida yo creo que yo yo yo creo que
lo que lo que la evidencia nos muestra
actualmente si hacemos un análisis rey
general de las democracias
latinoamericanas es que este el
autoritarismo puede ser tanto en
gobiernos de derecha como de izquierda y
de hecho pues con lo que estamos viendo
entre los países que son vecinos pues
creo que queda bastante digamos
representado usted lo que está pasando
en lo que ha pasado en venezuela en
cuanto a represión de la protesta social
a lo que está pasando actualmente en
colombia pues no pareciera que hay mucha
diferencia
o que la diferencia entre la forma en
que se reprimen
la protesta es una cuestión que sea solo
atraviese por el espectro ideológico si
vemos casos como el salvador pues
también vemos tendencias más hacia el
asia autoritarias hacia lo que pasa en
venezuela pero por ejemplo en el caso de
las campañas contra andrés manuel o lo
que está pasando en perú se ha vendido
esta idea de que es cual todo lo que
suena izquierda automáticamente sinónimo
de castrochavismo y yo creo que ni todas
las derechas son iguales ni todos los
gobiernos de izquierdas son iguales a
izquierdas quizás más moderadas a
izquierdas más pragmáticas y lo que lo
que discutimos anteriormente y lo que
vemos que relaté si lo comparamos con lo
que es una izquierda por ejemplo en un
país europeo frente a las izquierdas
latinoamericanas tenemos izquierdas que
son algo
ambiguas o contradictorias son
progresistas en algunos temas pero
siguen siendo muy conservadoras en otros
entonces lo que tenemos es la me parece
que realmente lo que se lamenta la el
discurso sobre el riesgo que implica que
un país
acerca venezuela es en la evidencia en
evidencia práctica no se cumple tanto y
se ha usado más como para generar un
miedo en el electorado sobre todo usando
estas denominadas face news y también
haciendo uso de de la desinformación que
se genera a través de redes sociales
donde realmente hay se corren muchos
rumores se corte se habla mucho de las
amenazas de lo que puede ser la
izquierda sin a veces tener un sustento
en sustento claro y creo que en el caso
mexicano también ilustra esto así a
usted referencia precisamente a la
protesta social no ahora teniendo en
cuenta toda esta crisis no que viene
acumulando pero hubo a lo largo ya de
hace varios años con mandatarios que no
pudieron terminar valga la redundancia
sus mandatos que enfrentan acusaciones
de corrupción sobre todo como explica
usted que quizás no ocurra en perú lo
que sucedió por ejemplo en chile lo que
está sucediendo por estos días en
colombia estos estallidos sociales
contra la clase es
dirigente no
si lo que vemos lo que vemos es lo que
te decía que eres en realidad la
protesta social y sobre todo enmarcado
en una situación compleja y complicada
como la que está atravesando el mundo
porque esto creo que es algo global pero
el caso de latinoamérica pues el impacto
que ha tenido la pandemia ha incidido en
que tanto en gobiernos de izquierda como
gobiernos de derecha haya protesta
frente a un modelo sobre todo en frente
a un modelo ya no lo pienso solo como
hacía no hacia política hacia las
políticas específicamente sino hacia un
modelo económico que ha mostrado que más
que digamos lograr condiciones de
equidad ha favorecido cierto cierta o
cierta desigualdad para nadie es un
secreto que en la actualidad america
latina es la región más insegura del
mundo y también una de las más violentas
entonces con combinemos desigualdad
combinemos en la violencia
en ciertos casos que digamos 50 de las
ciudades más peligrosas del mundo
por lo menos el 90 por ciento están en
en países latinoamericanos entonces a
eso le sumamos la pandemia y tenemos la
tormenta perfecta para la expansión de
la protesta social y sobre todo habría
que agregar agregarle otro ingrediente
que es la digamos las facilidades que
ahora las redes sociales dan también
para difundir y facilitan la
organización para para cierta acción
colectiva entonces creo que hay que hay
que señalar que el tema de la protesta
social también está muy ligado a lo que
hacen es uno podría considerarse como
parte de lo que ha generado la pandemia
ahora que las causas pueden ser más
profundas y que obedecen a temas
estructurales eso tampoco lo podemos
dejar a un lado pero sí creo que hay que
contextualizar que digamos que la
pandemia ha servido como catalizador
para para la protesta social en muchos
países de américa latina y casi en el
caso concreto de lo que está sucediendo
ahora en colombia que lleva más de un
mes en esa situación
bueno dejamos por un momento pero y
regresamos a mexico que recordemos vivió
su jornada electoral más grande de toda
su historia moderna no solo los
ciudadanos fueron a elegir a los 500
integrantes de la cámara de diputados
porque además méxico recordemos que se
divide en 32 entidades federales o
estados que incluyen a la ciudad de
mexico por supuesto y cada uno cuenta
con un gobernador o jefe de gobierno y
también su respectivo congreso y este
domingo los mexicanos estaban llamados
también a escoger a 15 de esos
gobernadores de los siguientes estados
que ven en amarillo en el mapa que vemos
en imágenes
hablamos de baja california baja
california sur campeche colima chihuahua
guerrero michoacán nayarit nuevo león
querétaro también san luís potosí
sinaloa sonora tlaxcala y zacatecas
además se renovarán 30 congresos locales
y unos 1900 ayuntamientos o alcaldías en
total están en juego cerca de 20 mil 500
puestos de elección popular una cifra
nunca
que hacen de estos unos comicios
históricos
saludamos ahora a este programa especial
de france 24
denso helguera él es analista político
en su bueno estamos hablando sobre las
elecciones en méxico también las
elecciones de perú pero bueno en este
momento nos encontramos en méxico no
muchísimos analistas consideran que
estos comicios son una suerte de
referendo no para evaluar lo que fue
esta mitad de gestión del presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador usted
coincide y en ese caso como evalúa esa
mitad de gestión
bueno definitivamente es una opinión en
la que coincido en relación a tener un
éxito relativo o no de la misma and han
salido en estos momentos algunas
encuestas de cierre que mencionaría que
el partido morena de gobierno estaría
perdiendo dos digamos gobernaciones
entonces esto va a tener que ser
analizado ya con los resultados
oficiales pero de momento es lo que se
está mencionando hay algunos estados en
los que están ganando los algunos
partidos independientes y se puede
hablar también en algunos conteos
rápidos
a nivel de diputaciones si están
cerrados entre partidos más
tradicionales como el pri el pan y
también en morena no evidentemente en
los resultados a nivel de gobernación si
tienen una lógica un poco más diferente
y además que hay una alianza de otros
partidos políticos para enfrentar a
morena en donde algunos casos les habría
dado un relativo éxito frente a las
mismas
hablemos ahora de la oposición cómo
llega a la oposición hablamos de una
alianza bastante heterogénea verdad con
partidos tradicionales como bueno el
histórico pri de centro el panel
conservador y también el pr de que es de
izquierda está todo el arco político en
una coalición esto podría hacer que se
pierdan votos digo al presentarse
fuerzas tan antagónicas o quizás por el
contrario ayudaría a lo que sería
digamos un voto rechazo no
mira yo creo que ayudaría a unificar el
voto de rechazo porque los partidos por
sí solos no tienen el liderazgo
necesario para que puedan y enfrentar a
manuel lópez obrador entonces en este
caso una causa común para adaptar el
antivoto y poder tener un enfrentamiento
más efectivo recordemos que morena llega
a captar a través de los restauradores
todo un grupo de descontento contra el
sistema y allí van muchos segmentos
ideológicos y muchas personas que
dejaron sus partidos tradicionales para
pertenecer o ser agrupados a este
partido político es tarea del primer bam
y de los otros partidos también en
fortalecerse sin embargo dadas las
circunstancias y las pérdidas de
representatividad de los partidos no les
tocó más que unificarse unificarse a
aquellos a quienes ahora están en contra
del sistema que representa el propio
manuel o restaurador y que no estarían
realizando con relativo éxito si se
confirman evidentemente los resultados
en relación a algunas pérdidas
importantes dentro de las gobernaciones
que evidentemente tuvo en principio
morena con como éxito rotundo y
contundente como fue la elección que él
arrastró
se podría decir que están a perdón
interrumpimos estos momentos vamos ya
mismo a perú porque está hablando
keiko fujimori candidata a la
presidencia en esta segunda vuelta
electoral escuchemos la es un primer
pronunciamiento sobre la base
de los resultados que hemos visto de la
encuesta de boca de urna hace minutos
atrás
estos resultados sin duda se han
recibido con la alegría
pero al ver que el margen es tan pequeño
es fundamental también mantener la
prudencia
y eso lo digo para todos los peruanos
esta campaña ya culminó
y será fundamental
como lo dije en la mañana
tender los puentes
y encontrar los espacios de diálogos
entre todos los grupos políticos
nuestro país al ver el mapa del
resultado en esta boca de urna lo que se
muestra son dos grandes bloques
con ciudadanos que todos quieren un
cambio
pero con una visión diferente de país
ese cambio
lo tiene que buscar gane quien gane
aquí no hay un ganador o un perdedor
aquí lo que se tiene que buscar
finalmente es la unidad
de todos los peruanos
por eso que desde ya invoco
a la prudencia a la calma a la paz
a ambos grupos a los que votaron y no
votaron por nosotros
por esa prudencia es que nosotros vamos
a esperar los resultados oficiales de la
onpe
agradecemos desde ya infinitamente adiós
a los peruanos por haberme dado esta
oportunidad
de haber participado en esta segunda
vuelta y pido a los personeros que sé
que están activamente todavía
defendiendo voto a voto que lo hagan
hasta el final que se queden hasta que
se cierre la última mesa desde ya a
todas las personas
a todos los grupos políticos
a todos los que nos han apoyado desde ya
les digo gracias muy amables
la palabra de tipo reflejo
escuchábamos a keiko fujimori candidata
a la presidencia de perú vamos a hacer
un breve repaso por algunas de sus
pronunciamientos dijo que bueno estaban
haciendo algunas encuestas a boca de
urna y que lo hacían con alegría con un
tono muy calmo llamó a mantener la
prudencia a tender puentes y diálogos
con todos los partidos habló de unos
resultados que muestran por supuesto
como veníamos adelantando dos grandes
bloques no una fragmentación una
polarización social que ha sido el tema
que hemos hablado con nuestros analistas
y que ha caracterizado también a todo
este proceso electoral dijo también y
cito sus palabras convocó a la prudencia
a la calma y a la paz a ambos grupos
haciendo referencia por supuesto a esta
polarización que decíamos y dijo por
supuesto que van a esperar los
resultados oficiales agradeció a dios
eso quisiera consultarle nos estuvo
escuchando las palabras de keiko
fujimori como las interpretas muchas
veces solemos
recibir las primeras palabras con
bastante entusiasmo se notó bastante
prudencia en las palabras de keiko
fujimori
por supuesto que con fujimori es hoy por
hoy
o aún la cantidad hasta no tener los
resultados formales pero con mayor
madurez recordemos que esta no es su
primera experiencia en una campaña
electoral y mucho menos en segunda
vuelta eso hace a una cantidad mucho más
cuajada
para poder llamar a la calma y no pecar
de ese entusiasmo que si lo tuvo en sus
obras dos campañas presidenciales en
donde evidentemente en último instante
por márgenes muy pequeños perdió
elecciones entonces él el ser una
candidata también bastante golpeada por
la experiencia de vida que ha tenido el
de tocar evidentemente le va a curtir en
cuanto a toda la toma de decisiones que
lleva que tiene que dar y los mensajes
que también manda elaboración
corresponde evidentemente eso a la
madurez política que hoy por hoy ella
tiene y que ha lucido en la segunda
vuelta electoral saludamos nuevamente
alfredo fernández de lara escuchábamos
recién las palabras de keiko fujimori
del partido de derecha fuerza popular
grandes de lara usted como interpreta
palabras que como decíamos parecen ser
están caracterizadas por cierta
prudencia hasta el momento
pues digamos con base en lo que también
tuve la oportunidad de oír me parece que
es un discurso prudente pero yo lo sentí
un poco desanimado también no sentí que
fuera un discurso de alguien que en
algún punto en algún punto lo sentí
derrotista y si me preguntás obviamente
en este sentido sería muy subjetiva mi
opinión pero incluso el lenguaje
corporal no me pareció de una candidata
que tuviera como certeza de que en este
momento
va a digamos va arriba
en los resultados yo lo sentí como
llamado a la cautela pero también me
parece que en una elección tan cerrada
salir a dar un discurso de este tipo
podría ser un arma de doble filo
a mí no me transmitió un mensaje de como
digamos como observador externo un
mensaje de seguridad de alguien que
considera que que está en proceso de un
triunfo electoral podría ser que me
equivoqué y podría ser una una postura
de madurez política pero no sé si en
este momento sea una cuestión de madurez
o de o de más bien de sentir que la
situación no le favorece electoralmente
eso quisiera resultarle a usted ahora me
vamos a regresar nuevamente a los
desafíos que enfrentará el presidente o
la próxima presidenta de perú álamos
previamente sobre la pandemia de
coronavirus porque perú no es un país
más en en frente a esta pandemia pero es
el país con la tasa de muertes per
cápita más alta de todo el mundo y
estamos hablando de un país alrededor de
32 millones de habitantes no es un dato
menor esta crisis sanitaria que
atraviesa el país eso en este sentido
quien considera a keiko fujimori o
castillo como cree que enfrentarán este
desafío y tantos otros no en materia de
seguridad y economía también
bueno en materia de la administración de
la crisis de la pandemia si fuera el
castillo en el próximo presidente lo que
haría es ir con la embajada rusia y por
la afinidad digamos ideológica y había
anunciado además que había tenido
conversaciones previas con el embajador
para poder surtir al país de las vacunas
de digamos de la faz de la fábrica o de
la manufactura rusa si fuera a keiko
fujimori en este aspecto
ella variaría un poco más el mercado y
continuaría con la política de sagasti
del actual presidente que ha tenido la
finalidad de poder adquirir una gran
variedad de vacuna pero prefiriendo la
vacuna pzifer que tiene hoy por hoy uno
de los mayores índices de confiabilidad
en el mundo si fuéramos a hablar de
materia de reactivación económica bueno
sinceramente y si me preocupara
relativamente ambos candidatos porque de
castillo no conocemos el plan exacto que
tienen para la economía porque él
manifestó que no iba a ser una política
de expropiación o muy similar a la de
digamos al chavismo valora turismo de
venezuela pero que iba a ser una
economía popular es decir una economía
a las necesidades del país pero jamás
dijo si va a ser por ejemplo el mercado
controlado y quien tan controlado lo
podía hacer como tenemos modelos que
varían desde china hasta el modelo de
brasil entonces ahí hay una gran gama de
operaciones pero si coincidía en que iba
a darle un mayor protagonismo al estado
regulador no es lo único que se pudo
escuchar de él en campaña mientras que
con timor y ha apostado por la
oportunidad del sistema pero la promesa
la gran cantidad de promesas para los
programas sociales de ayuda humanitaria
o ayuda social era inmensamente grande y
a veces desmedida una de las promesas
que llegó a realizar es que iba a
pagarle 10 mil soles lo que representa
un poco menos de tres mil dólares
por cada víctima de la pandemia como
responsabilidad del estado si hiciéramos
números evidentemente estaríamos
hablando de aproximadamente 200 mil
millones de soles no entonces es una
cifra bastante alta para una sola de sus
promesas seguramente van a tener que
recalibrar aquellas promesas populistas
que ambos candidatos tuvieron y que por
un lado uno no se puede definir
completamente bien y laboral lo hizo en
exceso obviamente hay otro tipo de
problemas como la seguridad ciudadana el
asunto también macroeconómico cómo está
olvidando la salud de la economía de un
país que tenía el tercer lugar en
reservas e internacionales dentro de
américa latina' sólo por debajo de
américa de méxico y brasil
y en la actualidad después de muchas
cantidades de subsidios de dinero habría
que tener allí una evaluación seria y
aquí las cifras oficiales no han sido
sinceras y muy expuestas en la
actualidad
disculpe eso quisiera ahora pasar con
alfredo fernández de lara nuevamente
para hablar con él sobre un tema clave y
que tiene que ver con que buscan los
selectores por un lado de keiko fujimori
como de castillo se podría aventurar que
los electores de pedro castillo buscan
digamos un cambio radical mientras que
los de keiko fujimori estarían buscando
cierta continuidad en el neoliberalismo
por ejemplo
pues digamos que lo que pareciera que
nos transmite un poco también digamos si
hubiera que pues lo que se ha hecho con
perfilar más o menos dónde está el apoyo
y entre qué actores está el apoyo de
keiko pues vemos que es un apoyo más de
tipo urbano más de clase media más de de
grupos que creen que el fujimorismo fue
una buena opción en su momento que
buscan como digamos cierta continuidad
mantener cierto status quo incluso pues
el apoyo que en su momento le brindó
pues recientemente le brindó
abiertamente un ex contrincante de su
propio padre me refiero a mario vargas
llosa pues si nos habla de un sector
como muy digamos de que busca que quizás
vienen keiko no sólo continuidad sino la
posibilidad de lograr cierta estabilidad
después de estos cinco años tan tan
inestables para para la
institucionalización y para la
democracia en perú y quizás si vemos el
perfil de castillo
a su apoyo su apoyo está más en zonas
rurales pues él es conocido como el
profe tiene digamos un perfil más hacia
hacia ciertos grupos sociales que quizás
no son los que se han visto favorecidos
por la por el modelo económico que
quizás son como el sector digamos donde
la pandemia ha impactado más y que
también consigue que quizás encuentran
en este en este discurso del combate a
la corrupción y de un cambio hacia un
modelo distinto pues la posibilidad de
verse involucrados un poco más y recibir
los beneficios de un sistema democrático
el tema es lo que se menciona que sería
una ruptura
por un lado keiko mantendría cierta
gobernabilidad como se mencionó
anteriormente pero aquí cabría
cuestionarnos si la gobernabilidad
también se traduce en reducir la
corrupción
se traduce en generar mejores
condiciones condiciones más equitativas
para todos o solo y no para ciertos
grupos entonces a veces parecería que la
gobernabilidad si garantiza mantener
cierto status quo pero a la larga
termina generando estas contradicciones
que nos llevan a que nos han llevado en
muchos casos como el peruano a algunas
luchas que parece que es entre la
continuidad y la ruptura más que buscar
digamos posiciones intermedias que
logren consensos y que logren digamos
mantener la gobernabilidad pero sin
sacrificar la estabilidad y la equidad
social ahora alfredo hablemos un poco
más del fujimorismo no el apellido
fujimori no es un apellido más en
absoluto y pesa muchísimo sobre keiko de
joyce ella fue primera dama del
exmandatario alberto fujimori a partir
de sus 19 años cuando se divorció
fujimori de su ex esposa ella incluso
defiende muchísimas de las medidas
tomadas por su padre ahora la pregunta
que le quiero hacer es lo siguiente no
que representa el fujimorismo hoy en día
en el año 2021 para la sociedad peruana
es una preocupación para algún sector
concreto
pues mira manteniendo un poco la tanto
el caso peruano como lo podría conceder
en su me atrevería a decir que él fungió
el fujimorismo pese a que sea digamos el
desenlace que tuvo alberto fujimori y
todo esto con los videoescándalos de
montesino y todo lo que esto generó pues
en cierta forma entre cierto sector
social fujimorismo en su momento fue
visto como un gobierno que le dio cierto
estabilidad a perú el problema es que
fue un gobierno que le dio esa
estabilidad quizás económica o esta
gobernabilidad política de la que
hablábamos a un costo que no
necesariamente sé si fue favorable en el
largo plazo para la democratización y
para la institucionalización finalmente
fujimori pues es conocido que hugo se
dio prácticamente un autogolpe entonces
ahí también es cuando a veces pareciera
que habría que recordar con mayor
detenimiento la historia porque si se me
acusa o se pretende decir qué
la llegada de castillo sería una ruptura
o un daño a las instituciones pues
recordemos un poco el caso de fujimori
no fue precisamente alguien que
fortaleció las instituciones
democráticas entonces ahí es donde
también hay que como que mesura y ver
que a veces lo que vuelve un poco a lo
que decía el problema es que en realidad
no es de instituciones sino de la
profundización de la
institucionalización y de que seguimos
en mezcla en regímenes que más que
democracias liberales
son democracias que oscilan mucho entre
posturas autoritarias y posturas digamos
democráticas en algunos sentidos
yo creo que fujimori mantiene un
respaldo a partir de esos logros pero
también insisto que me parece que los
costos de esos logros en el largo plazo
no tienen a perú en situaciones como la
que está actualmente y si a eso le
sumamos no solo fujimori sino la lista
de presidentes desde toledo y kuczynski
a todos los presidentes en los últimos
21 años
y su relación por ejemplo con odebrecht
lo que vemos es que el problema no sólo
era de un gobierno o de un líder de
liderazgo carismático o autoritario como
lo fue fujimori sino que el problema es
mucho más profundo y es como más
estructural pero sí me parece que el
daño que le hizo fujimori a la
democracia peruana pues se está
reflejando todavía el día de hoy pensó
que era letrado la misma pregunta que
representa el fujimorismo hoy en día
para la sociedad peruana tiene digamos
peso sobre todo en los sectores
opositores no digamos es un elemento un
factor para un voto de rechazo contra
keiko fujimori
pero fujimori en primera vuelta ha sido
la candidata política con mayor rechazo
de entre todos los candidatos en segunda
vuelta ha significado una esperanza
dentro de un juego de temores contra el
candidato el castillo el fujimorismo
hoy por hoy dentro de los de la votación
de alrededor del 13 por ciento que
obtuvo keiko fujimori en primera vuelta
es en realidad el voto más sólido y duro
que ella ha podido obtener sin embargo
el resto de la oración es una simpatía
prestada contra una nación ya que la
mayor parte de estos de esos votantes se
ha manifestado públicamente en calles y
en redes de iu con los mensajes
en relación a doha no votamos por keiko
fujimori porque nos representen sino
porque es la mejor opción que tenemos
frente a una amenaza mayor que el
fujimorismo tenga la oportunidad de
reivindicarse en relación al pasado no
solamente del padre sino de la propia
vida o fujimori que se ha visto además
obligada a admitir errores a teniendo
performance que nunca antes había tenido
como política por día jamás admitió y
asumió un solo error entonces en esta en
esta situación coyuntural tienen ellos
una oportunidad pero además una gran
dificultad que evidentemente no va a
gobernar como una mayoría del parlamento
no van a gobernar o una gran simpatía de
todos los partidos políticos seguramente
van a tratar de hacer una especie de
gobierno o un gobierno con algunas
líneas políticas que haya tenido que
negociar con otros partidos políticos
para tener su apoyo en la actualidad
pero todo ello va a invitar
que va a tener reglas muy fino y mostrar
una muñeca política aún más madura de lo
que ha sido como cantidad eso va
un reto muy impensable de colocarnos en
los zapatos propios pero veis es algo
que en definitiva es va a tener que
realizar y va a tener que ejercer un
liderazgo y aquí vamos a ver digamos o
veríamos de qué materia estaría hecho la
nueva imagen del fujimorismo perdón es
sólo los interrumpo nos quedan menos de
poco poco más de dos minutos de programa
pero quisiera preguntarle a cada uno
comenzamos con alfredo sus conclusiones
para ambos procesos le pido un minuto no
más por favor alfredo listo para el caso
mexicano pues me parece que el andrés
manual mantiene un apoyo de alrededor
del 63 por ciento me parece que no va a
lograr la mayoría calificada quizás en
términos digamos de la elección como tal
pero creo que va a mantener una mayoría
en el congreso creo que tiene la
capacidad para negociar y eso podría
para que pueda mantener cierta
influencia en el legislativo en el caso
peruano me parece que la polarización
está ahí y que independientemente de que
de quien gane en este momento
quien gane va a enfrentar un sistema
bastante inestable en términos de
legitimidad en sus conclusiones no queda
un minuto nada más perdón mire en perú
con con serenidad sobre unas elecciones
que pueden resultar bastante polémicas
los retos para quien sea que gane las
elecciones son fuertes son grandes y
muchas veces hasta podríamos decir
impensables hay mucho que hacer mucho
que revertir mucho que mejorar por el
bien de la población peruana y en méxico
creo yo que esta elección puede
representar una pérdida del poder de
andrés manuel lópez obrador y de morena
sobre todo en las elecciones locales que
son la base para las próximas
presidenciales así tendrán la oposición
que dar de una manera estratégica más
fuerte en caso podría ser una victoria
relativa en estas elecciones y amorena
tratar de rectificar o mejorar aquello
en lo que fallo que a estas alturas
resulta bastante complicado en la
personalidad del presidente mexicano
muchísimas gracias de esta manera
llegamos al final de este programa
especial de france 24 dedicado a dos
jornadas electorales claves en américa
latina la de perú por un lado y la de
mexico por el otro
agradecemos a quien hicieron parte de
este programa alfredo fernando
de lara francisco belaunde y también en
solier a todos ellos analistas y a
nuestros corresponsales mario' carbonell
francisco zacarías y anabella con más
gracias por acompañarnos sigan en
france24
[Música]